I mean can you believe how festive it is
in here Jimmy Carr are you just losing
your mind feces
I mean isn't it nice it's okay nice
wouldn't be the adjective you do okay
okay okay we we you know we don't do
festive that naturally I can I can I
guess if I was gonna recast the grin
would be an excellent choice just whose
causality I based on knows Oh based on
knows the man that I can I can see into
your nostrils from here right
it would lead me to believe that you're
gonna ruin Christmas right yeah well
it's not it's probably right we don't
like Sam's beard it just doesn't look
right
I'm not well I mean depends what you
want to look like I mean if you want to
I guess I guess I'm looking it it's a
look a lot of sex offenders have now is
if you're trying to attract children no
no I wasn't trying it yet I don't want
to attract what you don't want to
attract children no not a pedophile okay
so you want to you want children to be
disgusted by you
no it's that part it's not the
children's thing I didn't realize I
liked them crying before they're in the
van yeah I would say Art Garfunkel mid
breakdown okay that's you listening to
the best ever Paul Simon right right
that's that's thanks who's going how
long you grown it for I don't have any
sort of the specific ristin Tuki a very
handsome man what he does every year
yeah is he he's briefing you his bait a
vain as the next man so what he does pre
birthdays birthday is January 10th so he
grows a beard for three months before
his birthday every year and then shaved
it off on his birthday so then his
birthday it's like I'm 45 but people
can't my god you look amazing it takes
off ten years right does it make you
look younger it's a nice pre birthday
just a thought right when I need that
when I need that extra boost for
something whether it's a birthday or
whatever feel you need that boost now
yeah yeah well I can only use it once
I'm probably gonna need it very quickly
again after one seat once a year they'll
do you yeah
Televi had it it's only since October
middle of October okay
you know
while analyzing your looks this leads to
your hair that suggests a do you
remember it Easter used to I know it's
not festival Easter used to get those
eggs that you decorate it sure sure sure
kind of you have the look of the head
shape like an egg has been dipped in the
hair is it's just stuck all right it's a
wig it looks like it's hair from from a
barber's floor with crazy blue and like
a it looks like a five-year-old's done
you know you go great job right
six-year-old you go well I think we need
to get you into specialized I see like
it looks like it might have been taped
to a popsicle stick or something like
that like a child decorated egg right
come into your show I feel like I'm
giving you a hunt no you're right it's
very hostile you're right I'm feeling
very I'm kind of feeling attacked but
he's not wrong it's hard to argue he's
not wrong very hard to argue but still
my feeling is attacked yeah yeah so
tough welcome Jimmy Carr it's great to
have you here let's pray nice to be I've
never seen that the serious looks so
empty I kind of walk you through
everyone seems to have their own
vacations yeah yeah they've gone back to
their families their loving beautiful
families but obviously the whole thing
about your show is obviously that won't
be happening no no no now for some of us
know where to go what are you doing for
the holidays oh nothing I mean we quit
we're not we're not big I'm not a big
family guy either
I don't feel like this time of year is
so difficult if you don't have that
perfect setup right you don't have three
beautiful children or you're gonna see
your you know enormous family somewhere
it always feels like I've ever kind of
oh I guess are you in a relationship
yeah oh okay so yeah let's do that
oh yeah what what presumably you just
it's a it's a it's a fist okay Merry
Merry Christmas Jim's looking at a
lonely holiday yeah he's looking at so
many people are it's like it's I don't
think it's that unusual I think more
people are like it's almost like that
that Instagram sort of thing of people
trying to present oh we're going home
for holidays it's gonna be great is it
it really isn't
it's those days between Christmas and
New Year that are the toughest as well
cuz Italy Christmas there's a bit of
format that you can okay we're eating
10,000 calories and trying to you know
watch this movie and there's sports or
something
least that some those days in between
it's just like well they're also an
alcoholic it's tough what are you doing
for the chrisrip where will you be on
Christmas actual Christmas Day I'm going
to a restaurant this year I've decided a
restaurant waiting winner in New York
England okay and we're gone with an
another couple of some other friends of
ours so we're gonna go to a restaurant
there's no washing up there's nothing to
do we just have to get there and then
get home and then is that thing of like
it's basically like being in an eating
competition right but the whole day is
like oh right I'm going to try and do
15,000 calories of food that I would
never look at a plate of food that I
would go well is that for everyone yeah
many seconds of that and then somehow go
yeah no I need dessert right of course
we're celebrating
sure what are we celebrating again I
believe the birth of Jesus Christ it's
his birthday yeah Christ's birthday
Christmas he's born on Christmas well
then somewhere around Christmas yeah
they say live summarize what it seems I
mean when I was a kid I had an imaginary
friend he went everywhere with me and I
could talk to him and even hear me I'm a
he could grant me wishes and stuff and
running I grew up and I stopped going to
church right he realized it's silly I
mean it seems it just seems so
incredibly far fetch I also get the like
the idea that you go Jesus Christ died
for our sins that's great yeah and every
and that I get this story of it I get
the idea of the story of Christ on white
such a great story it's like every movie
everything was yeah the movies great
everything was kind of stripped away and
everything that were all that remained
was him and it's about rebirth yeah
second coming that yeah I get the idea
of it but the idea that you go from that
to cranberry sauce I need to get
cranberry sauce involved in this right
right even the resurrection and eggs I
kind of get like new life but the idea
that you go yeah what we're gonna need
is yeah so you're saying that if this
spirit has been lost of Christmas yeah
you're saying that his true intention is
not being on I'm just saying it's a
stretch it's a stretch some some of the
things you go yeah we get presents why
because he got gold frankincense and
myrrh I mean that seems but you know
that seems like [ __ ] doesn't it it
does I don't think it happened for a
baby I don't think it I don't think
anything happened I went to Israel
earlier in the year you did I think gigs
in Israel and how are they I'm went it's
great fun and obviously we went to
Palestine as well one more there because
I'm pretty woke I think you know that
about me
how'd you begin to Palestine oppa well
were you bitten perfect that's I mean
it's literally that easy it's like
people think there's a there's a big
it's like what are you nervous going in
there no not to who did you go with
somebody who's callous Tinian no know
what it is a weird thing that happens
when you go from so we're in the center
of overstaying Jerusalem you get in a
cab and you drive to a car park in like
this little demilitarized zone you get
out of one cab and the cab driver looks
at the other guy and goes alright the
Palestinian dude you get into the other
cab driven by the Palestinian because
then you do the rest of the journey in
the other camp Wow okay
it's kind of freaky but we went to bet
then we went to see the church where
Jesus was born I mean all I said was
this is it's a remarkable historical
site this is the oldest fleecing
tourism's how far into Palestine is it
oh it's like it's it's a it's a bit of a
trip it's like so you know half an hour
in there oh yeah I I feel like Christmas
is kind of morphed into something where
most people in life just kind of need a
need a win sometimes you just need to
celebrate at times there's enough misery
going on it's not like this is a
Christian thing this has been going on
paganism the midwinter festival and that
where the tree comes from it's always
been there yeah you need that you need
to have a day where it's like okay let's
just let's be happy don't ask why we're
happy let's just be happy today we got
every other day of the year to be
miserable I think that's what Christmas
is nice yeah yeah I like that yeah it's
a happy day no you gotta come to my
house dude I may be well yeah I don't
know if you if you're going to his house
surely I mean you've only got to bring
some recording equipment I want to hear
that sure you do yeah my just because I
do have that thing that perfect family
said of my my parents will be there and
then my siblings and their kids and my
kid and the whole thing it'll be it'll
be very picturesque you and then Jim
shows up whoa wait you got a kid yes he
does
oh yeah Jimmy Carr I left it in yeah he
won't pull out yeah I Sam's a breeder no
no no you ask anybody
oh yeah I left it in ya know my mother
and both holes ya know I have an a I
have a child he's getting ready to enjoy
Christmas how old is the kid doesn't
he'll be 2 in that's the age when in a 2
to 6 is the age when you compare so
don't you can enjoy sir okay yeah yeah
like last year he was like a lump so it
didn't didn't matter he didn't know what
was going on yeah maybe this year he
finally understands name yeah lump yeah
yeah yeah I named him after the
President of the United States of
America song but yeah but that's what
I'll be doing and I'd like Jim to join
my holiday why not
you know because you see each other
every other day we like each other
that's true we do we do see each other a
lot but you know if there'll be other
people around you like a married couple
you're also not having sex exactly Wow
Wow we started started only in the mouth
we're not a couple of queers if you
don't push back that's right that's
right that's the strategy and we're
probably gonna just sit around and binge
the fix that's that's the plan that is
your show oh it's such a weird
coincidence good time right now yeah I
think it's pretty good actually this
this new one I mean I make a lot of
these panel shows back in the UK right
but I like panel shows is like they're a
huge thing in the UK it's like that's
how we do stand-up comedy on television
there's some stand-up on as well but
right basically that's what stand-ups do
they you know we don't have this kind of
radio culture in the same way as in
America so people come on and they sit
on a show and they talk about this
week's news though they talk about
whatever whatever this shows about in
that kind of how James Corden got his
format for his late-night show it's kind
of how it's done in the UK a little more
but James used to do a lot of my shows
used to come on as a guest and sort of
sit and talk about whatever the week's
news and yeah yeah those who come as the
show in in the UK called a league of
their own which sought about sports
I see a sports car it's really funny and
then we Netflix said I won't come and do
one for us
so we don't want about it's like every
episode is about a different massive
problem in the world
so like opioid crisis gun control
immigration all lighthearted funds yeah
and then and then we've come up with
like each team it's me as hosting and a
lady called Katherine Ryan on one team
and deal I like Katherine yeah the funny
and D Alice and di like two is great
yeah and they come up with massive
solutions like really kind of
interesting out there fun solutions but
that could maybe actually work to these
huge problems here's why I like to show
because I sit there when I found out
that the Netflix was just doing this I
go oh it's another show where comedians
come on and tackle problems and don't
tell any jokes and just sit there here
is what needs to be done and I'm like I
don't I don't need that but you guys
have actually remembered that we can
make this funny and it's a good time and
it's fine you're not first and foremost
cuz I mean it's not politicized you know
so that thing of like it's not this
week's news and now there's slightly the
issue with a lot of these shows
especially for Netflix because people
watch Netflix one day want to watch it
right now you say oh the shows on
tonight their shows on what you want it
to be on exactly they're kind it's
interesting actually nepalese when you
go you can't say good evening or good
night at the end of the show because
they kind of go no you can watch it
whenever they want yeah watch it at 6:00
a.m. in the morning if you want do you
think right but that that's sort of that
bit about going it's kind of current
issues rather than you know rather than
it being this week's topical oh if you
miss it this week and and they're kind
of there's a lot of shows doing a
sideways look at the news but just going
all the world is [ __ ] I mean weird in
all kinds of trouble rather than just
going well what would you do about it so
the first five or six minutes of this
show every week is us going okay I guess
the aging population is a problem but
then we come up with a great solution
which is shut down Florida when what
would show him down Florida do well
basically the issue is we've got an
aging population they retire yeah about
60 and they go to Florida and they have
a great time and they stop contributing
to society and they start they become a
burden yeah society yes dude we have to
encourage people to work for longer
right that's easy to do if you if you're
living in Detroit you got no place to go
right because if you live in Detroit and
you go oh I gave up my job what do you
do no I sit at home and I'm cold
fighting do or don't give up your job
keep working okay I'll keep working
because otherwise five seven days a week
I'm just hanging out in Detroit yeah I
don't want to do that it's that thing if
you go would you hate your wife you have
to get out of the house right but if
you're in Florence in Florida
and they go what you can go golfing all
day and you go through an amazing
retirement we're we're kind of killing
the idea of retirement so we shut down
in Florida we don't shut it down for
everyone
mmm we just say no one over the age of
50 is allowed into Florida oh my god
it's brilliant just douchebags and we
also control America's Got a huge douche
bag problem it's a major we do and we
contain it in Florida becomes the jet
ski Spring Break place because if the
douchebags find out there's no old
people and there's more room they're all
going
oh it's fine yeah yeah I mean and then
obviously there's there's a there's a
you know there's a douchebag cleansing
program I've got lined up for next year
sirs and the old people won't work if
they're in their regular places and not
[ __ ] being lazy in Florida quite
right yeah yeah that makes perfect sense
but then we've got I'll tell you the
other idea that I think might appeal to
you guys right so we looked at the
problem with social media so people are
incredibly unhappy on social media
people that are on Twitter people are
talking about it suicides are up I'm
sorry
suicide more people die now from suicide
event from violence crazy I mean it's
it's insane
very violent country you would think
yeah you would think yet more people are
taking themselves out you know you know
when you say you're your own worst enemy
yeah actually that is the case it's
happening we're best friend depends on
how you look at it yeah really great
generally positive
everyone's worried about Jim this
Christmas I'm begging him at this point
what if you needed a license to go on
the internet it's that easy you just
need a license so everything you do on
the internet would be available for
public view so you wouldn't be unlike
Twitter trolling wouldn't exist a
license if it was Oh Sam Roberts said no
you should go kill yourself right but if
it's you know you know at at 1 2 3 . 8-3
true like so no more anonymity you know
again no anonymity but also like your
porn searches would be vastly different
if people could come in oh my god the
next morning and go what were you
looking at last night
Jim's would be interestingly exactly the
same yeah no filter on Jim Norton no
you're a hundred percent right sometimes
that like going to see you live I think
sometimes which I've done for many years
but don't I see you live it does feel
like you're looking at a guy you go oh
all of I do all of that stuff but it's
all in the vault right somehow you're
like most of your comedy I feel comes
from you don't have a vault or the keys
been lost somewhere yeah
does it ever occur to you that this
stuff belongs in a vault or do you go
well I do this closet really well but do
you just have that mindset like I do
this and it's funny this is what I
should be talking about pretty much yeah
you don't think about like oh you know
I'm just gonna be honest man no no I
just find it's what I'm lazy so I just
talk about my life I don't want to sit
down and write Jim Norton is too lazy to
lie that should be the name of you next
specializing too lazy to lie yeah
absolutely sums up and I'd say I like it
it's what when it's like like that you
know there you watch the specials and
the specialist obviously that's a show
that's been toured and it's been honed
and it right an hour of stand-up comedy
that all works in a row but I like it
when it's the Comedy Cellar when you're
working out a new bed yeah yeah
sometimes it's just you say something
that's just disgusting
no on the end of it that is my favorite
Jim Norton stuff is like what did he why
would he do why would he tell me about
yeah that wasn't necessary yeah yeah
sometimes Plus flash is top of mind the
whole audience is sitting there going
you know we're not your therapist yeah
there are time you paid to listen to
this there are times where it doesn't go
as planned right tonight you're like the
punchline will be there and then you get
there and you go whoops nope I just I
just end it on a sad fact sorry folks
are interesting sure I think it's good
it's not a bad idea I love it yet taking
away the anonymity now people argue that
in order to be truthful some people need
to be anonymous there are jobs that our
professions there's all this I think the
original idea of anonymity being
protected was so that people was to
protect speech so what would you say to
those people
the night here okay well I think you
know if there are there are certain
places within our society where you know
anonymity is sacrosanct like voting like
people aren't you have to vote in a
little booth and then everyone talks
about how they voted anyway right
they're stickers on Instagram and yes no
that is true everyone everyone's pretty
open about what they do you know so I
don't see that that's a huge issue yeah
people have changed in that respect that
you don't when somebody said oh yeah I
voted today you already know who they
voted for you know why they voted you
know what they're thinking cuz they
haven't stopped talking about who
they're gonna vote for they can't stop
bragging about how proud they are for
they voted folks who gives a [ __ ] right
nobody cares no one cares you're not
changing anything it's like the lack of
anonymity is kind of an interesting
thing someone told me an interesting
fact the other day kind of tangential to
talking about the show but I was my
friend bought I went to Tokyo recently
he bought a new iPhone when he was in
Tokyo this is exactly the same as the
ones here there's a little bit cheaper
because it was Tokyo and you can't turn
off the camera noise I said what he said
you know the camera noise you know it
makes that clicking noise when you know
the camera you can turn it off on your
phone cause you can't do that too much
upskirting in Tokyo apparently yeah
they're all exactly I went well that's
what that's a so by law they made it so
all the cameras have to make a noise
yeah that's actually not a bad idea
wow that's a not a bad idea that sounds
like something that would have come up
on your show who would have thought of
that to be like well here's what we'll
do we just make it so you can turn off
the sound how do you turn the camera
mine's off just but but not for those
reasons how do you turn it I think I
don't think they ever let it let you I
don't know what the function is on that
but you mind's never been on yeah I turn
the noise the vibrate thing I just get
one in Japan it's there is even if your
phones on silent vibrate whatever in the
theater you've got it all locked down on
airplane mode she still makes the noise
Wow
I'm kind of brilliant I heard my camera
before I'm trying to I'm scrolling
through to see there's a way to turn off
or is it only when my volume is uh I
don't know if I think for me cuz I don't
futz with it by itself when I turn the
ringer on the cameras on but I almost
never have the ringer on oh no I'm
getting all I'm getting this that my
cameras been flickering by the way on
this waiting flickering yeah there is
when you turn the other he's he's
cameras been flickering what what it
means is I'm having a stroke
my cameras go my cameras gone weird it's
got all shaky my hands
somebody called 9-1-1 no it flickers
like when you turn when you hit the
little button the volume button no watch
when you put it on photo it like and now
it's not doing it of course now really
did phasing on our tech advice now I was
just gonna show that I wasn't making it
up I'm like an apple genius right just
because you know about iPhones in Tokyo
sure yeah Tokyo but that so that's the
idea of this is like coming up with
really crazy ideas that might just work
my favorite is the global warming one
that actually would work what is the
idea well we came up with to the format
of the show is each team comes up with
an idea and then the audience vote and
then Netflix I guess fix the world and
they've got a lot of money this will
leave that to them but this is where
you're smart the competition part
actually makes people invested it's the
other thing well yeah because you've got
to make it like I mean it's not like I
always and I said on the thing to
Katherine's here look we can't you can't
just like [ __ ] on the other person's
idea because there's no fun in that
right let them have their thing you have
your idea they have their idea there's
no like right it's not debate team
you're not going all that would never
work like be a celebrate it's fun right
but the ID so Katherine's idea on global
warming was we rebrand veganism cuz this
is an interesting fact you know I mean
veganism may be a little bit smug sure
quite slightly I haven't noticed but
I've heard people say it sure fun fact
is possible to be vegan and shut the
[ __ ] up really like don't use it as a
substitute for personality it's just
quite a healthy way to eat but you don't
have to go on about it so that's got
like one thing we made an advert for
that in that's fun deals idea though
game-changer set up a volcano
now genuinely if you want to cool down
the world by like two three degrees if
you set up a volcano because the ash
goes up into the high atmosphere and it
reflects the light is that
scientifically true the great thing
about this it's already been tested
we've already done it when Krakatoa went
off about 150 years ago
yeah the earth cooled by two degrees
there was no summer in Europe the next
year they just didn't have a summer
didn't happen so obviously there are you
know the people that live near the
volcano they might get a little bit
upset but Talan before we're doing it
yeah we'll let him know give me 6 months
to move you want to do that great yeah I
guess it's gonna be an amazing surprise
but that's genuinely a thing that could
work and you kind of you look so you
know that thing with politics like
people are bored of politics because
there's no radical ideas and so after
like the most radical thinker like even
you know bernie is like i'll we put up
or income tax by three percent okay
right okay old business rates down by
ten percent right it's not like a it's
not a radical
come on idea and when they do present a
problem eventually you can talk about it
all you want but you get to a point
where yeah but nothing's gonna change
and you go yeah you're probably right
it's the same thing over and over again
so that's why i guess that's why you're
saying talking politics is just it's
like it's for gonna but and it's fun
talking about like big radical ideas
yeah but actually why couldn't that work
that writing that could happen we came
up with an idea for like gender
inequality that i thought was pretty
good as well really well so there's
there's a pay gap there's women earn 80
cents in the dollar okay right men more
cutter and a better better at stuff yeah
better stuff sure so the way you redress
that is you set up a religion Judaism as
in judge judy or Judy Garland I see but
you set up religion Judaism and
religions gets tax breaks okay so you
like Scientology gets a huge it's a
basically a huge tax break so what you
do set up religions for women only men
cannot join uh-huh and you they join up
and they get paid through that and they
get like a kickback of twenty percent
they make up the difference so you're
saying that you couldn't sit there like
realistically and ask the government to
say give women tax breaks right is that
sexist that's ridiculous but if you had
a religion that was only for women the
tax break would be built in it's already
in our laws we don't need to change
anything and we're good to go yes that
makes sense that could what and that
could be I think I'm just just leveling
the playing field
how a less complicated solution than
having the government do it but that
would mean that women would have to
sacrifice the religion that's true that
they haven't said it wouldn't be good
Muslims or Jews or Catholics because it
would be their religion yeah I mean well
who Joe there were marriage who would
you raise the kid what religion would
raise the kid the boy and the girl
growing up in different religions yeah I
mean it's not like a religion it's a
religion like Scientology is a religion
it's like it's you know like a club like
a club
like a little group and yeah I guess the
religious tenant of it might be and also
whatever other faith you have good luck
yeah okay so you can yeah you can face I
really like Mohammed and also Judge Judy
so you're thinking like I like a multi
Thea multi theology yeah let's go yeah
okay yes I don't know if that's good I
think that Stephanie Norwood no it's not
I'm not play Scrabble with him that's a
nightmare parts of the word Oh Marty's
good multis good yeah theological is a
word sure yeah but you did you say I
said theological Cola called a multi
theology maybe so some of the end there
we kind of we drifted what we did sure
from words but we were we got there yeah